hello and welcome to
uh
i'm happy to welcome you to the second
of uh this year's frankie lectures in
the humanities here at the whitney
humanities center
each year the annual frankie lectures in
the humanities organized in conjunction
with an upper level undergraduate
humanities seminar the lectures are made
possible by the generosity of richard
and barbara frankie and are intended to
present important topics in the
humanities to a wide and general
audience
the fall 2021 frankie lectures in the
humanities has been organized in
conjunction with the yale college
seminar mass incarceration in the soviet
union and the united states
and it's a tremendous honor to to
present uh today's speaker
khalil gibran muhammad is the ford
foundation
professor of history race and public
policy at the harvard kennedy school
and director of the institutional
anti-racism and accountability project
he is the former director of the
schomburg center for research in black
culture a division of the new york
public library and the world's leading
library and archive of global black
history
he's the author of the award-winning uh
condemnate the condemnation of blackness
race crime uh and the uh and the making
of modern urban america
and a contributor to a 2014 national
research council study the growth of
incarceration in the united states
exploring causes and consequences he is
currently co-chairing a national
academies of sciences report on reducing
racial inequalities in the criminal
justice system and i know that uh that
it's not an award but i regularly
describe this book as one of the most
important books in the 21st century um
it bears it's about the united states
but it is i think
maybe the best book certainly one of the
best books ever written on the misuse of
objectivity on the ideological misuse of
objectivity
khalil is a frequent reviewer and
commentator in national print and
broadcast media outlets such as the
washington post the nation national
public radio pbs newshour msnbc and the
new york times which includes his sugar
assay for the 1619 project also a
remarkable piece
he has appeared in a number of
feature-like documentaries including the
recently released amend the fight for
america 2021 the oscar nominated 13th
2016
and slavery by another name
khalil is an award-winning teacher at
harvard and has received numerous honors
for his commitment to public engagement
such as ebony power 100 and the
distinguished service medal from
columbia university's teachers college
he serves on several boards including
the vera institute of justice cure
violence global and the museum of modern
art and uh just before i begin i hand
things over to professor muhammad he's
going to speak for 45 to 50 minutes then
professor snyder and i the co-teachers
conveners of the seminar we'll we'll
talk with him for five minutes or so
while you uh put questions in the
question box and then we will moderate
the 45-minute
question session uh with your questions
to professor muhammad okay thank you
thank you very much jason thank you uh
jason professor schneider to anna uh to
all the people who support this lecture
series it's indeed an honor to
visit
this seminar series as well as to be
part of the yale virtual community this
evening i have a lot of friends there
and indeed jason mentioning the work of
the national academies on a report on
reducing racial inequalities in the
criminal justice system i'm also joined
by tracy mears and elizabeth hinton two
friends and colleagues
who are working very hard on this report
so in any case uh tonight's lecture
is both
tied to the
readings that the students have read
as well as some continuing thoughts of
my own and borrowing from the work of
some of my colleagues who continue to
broaden our understanding
of the punitive roots of u.s society and
with that i thought it opened with a
little bit of a context setting
drawing on newer scholarship by my
colleagues kelly lido hernandez and dan
berger about settler colonialism and
then launch into a bit more directed
focus on
the topic of tonight's lecture
so so with that i'm going to do just a
tiny bit of reading and then walk
through
the material for this class
so
in many ways
lots of people have been focused on the
question of why the united states
at this moment in history is the most
punitive nation in the world and of
course it's almost wrote to say that by
population by per capita rates and by
expenditures the united states exceeds
all other nations and how many of its
citizens asylum seekers and undocumented
immigrants are under some form
of criminal legal supervision
and over the past two decades there's
been an explosion of reports by
government agencies non-profits
institutional advocacy organizations so
on and so forth exploring the dimensions
of what some would argue is
[Music]
before
and while these empirical and
comparative data on the size and scope
of this system and its many quote
unquote clients will continue to lie at
the heart of many of these reports only
within the past decade i'd say have
people really begun to take history
seriously
and so asking the ques answering the
question
which i think animates much of the
seminar why the united states by
comparison to say the soviet union
is so punitive uh may be the most
relevant question to answer and not
simply to document its size scale and
scope
and the challenge of answering this
question making it perhaps the most
difficult one to settle is
not the lack of various historical
drivers or causes or even the range of
possible philosophical explanations for
how americans have imagined crime sin
human nature and the utility of
punishment going back to the
enlightenment period the problem is of
course that these historical and
philosophical explanations have often
been least credible or authoritative in
explaining mass incarceration among
policymakers
and this seems to me to be a larger
problem about empiricism about the
relationship of criminal justice
practitioners
and their role in providing technical
assistance
a kind of coziness that has emerged of
the past 50 years with regard to the
study of crime and criminalization and
the actual practitioners in law
enforcement
courts
as well as in corrections
and therefore the disconnect between the
primary knowledge producers of criminal
justice and just about everyone else
has grown wider
and so one of the legacies
of this disconnection is
the dismissal of history as an important
uh tool to understand how we got here
that as i've already suggested has
changing
is beginning to change
so let me set the scene a kind of long
history that i think helps to put my
more immediate concerns for this
evening's uh talk in context
from the beginning the united states has
been what the historian dan berger calls
a captive nation
in the summer of 2019 of course
uh many people within the united states
and some places around the world
commemorated the 400th anniversary
of at least the landing of 20 or so
africans in virginia and that this
moment represented a kind of attempt to
reflect on the fact that
in american history there's no moment
when european european descended people
did not use racialized forms of
punishment war or containment against
indigenous tribes immigrants or enslaved
people of african descent settler
colonists first used the logic of
elimination then turned to ideas of
exploitation to make way for
their permanent residency two and a half
centuries before the nation was founded
and for nearly a century after the core
institutions of american democracy and
economy were built on the land of the
indigenous and the backs of the enslaved
as stanberger writes quote race
especially anti-black racism has been
the primary modality through which this
pairing of colonization and confinement
has transpired in the united states
forcible consignment haunted black life
from capture in africa through the
middle passage and sail in the americas
and he continues chattel slavery
initiated a racial regime rooted in
confinement plantation slavery was as
much a carceral force as the early
penitentiary
the historical institutions of native
reservations and african-american
slavery were the most durable legacies
of a number of ideas and ideologies that
helped forge the punitive foundations of
american society the frontier myth of a
virgin land waiting to be tamed and
cultivated by a master race animated
much of the colonial justification for
native displacement in genocide as
generation after generation of white
colonists and later citizens moved west
the choice to define native populations
and mexicans as quote savages or
criminals by law
custom or practice rationalize the
eventual creation of the nation from sea
to sea the european that europeans did
not encounter the legal restrictions and
physical constraints of the old world
and turned to religion to justify
conquest gave them a sense of legitimacy
to what they called manifest destiny
philosophers and political theorists
from adam smith to john locke and thomas
hopps thomas hobbes helped justify
conquest as the march of civilization by
the 19th century a system of federalism
had evolved which maximized various
states monopolies on violence to ensure
conquered indigenous and mexican land
would be converted to private property
by whites and capitalized by catalyzed
black people
and so what is at stake in this early
sketch or this stake sketch of the early
history of the united states is
precisely and let me pause here and say
this slowly
of the law itself
at all times a white outlaw culture that
rewarded brute force and strength of
arms against racialized others unsettles
basic assumptions about how we are to
understand criminalization and
punitiveness over time that is who is
counted as criminal and to what extent
the state has used violence or
punishment
in kelly lydon hernandez's recent study
city of inmates conquest rebellion and
the rise of human caging in los angeles
for which among many other
accomplishments she won a macarthur
genius award she found a remarkably
stable pattern of criminalization
incarceration going back to a single
carceral site in the tonga basin once
part of mexico named for the native
community that originally occupied the
land for seven millennia
what is today modern los angeles and
here i'll begin to shift uh to this
portion of the lecture
if someone could just let me know that
you see only the slide and not a bunch
of noise in the background that would be
helpful
but if you do here why don't i do this
sorry for the pause i know this is
always a little awkward when you're
working with one screen
so you should see mostly the slide
what you see there is a depiction of a
19th century los angeles jail and part
of what you want to draw your attention
to
is the seamlessness with which the space
of incarceration fits within the larger
commerce
and economy of this growing city
what she writes is that what is today
modern los angeles
crime and punishment emerged as the
platform for the racialized inequities
established during the colonial era to
flourish in the republic of mexico by
the 1820s the new nation's jails prisons
and convict labor crews were overcrowded
with the historically marginalized the
old colonial order largely a population
of natives africans mulattos and
mestizos she writes as displaced or
landless people they were arrested on
public order charges ranging from
vagrancy
disorderly conduct and drunkenness she
notes that in order for manifest destiny
to have become more than a proclamation
or a simple fact of conquest by treaty
the law needed an infrastructure and let
me note here that the arc of time
between
the charges of disorderly conduct or
drunkenness or what would later be
called status offenses
will have a powerful resonance later in
this lecture
she notes that the law needed an
infrastructure the local jail therefore
represented the foundational structure
she writes of u.s conquest in los
angeles she continues it was how the
rule of law was established
by 1850 the city passed an ordinance
that deputized all whites on complaint
of any reasonable citizen
and of course the very definition of
citizen excluded the very groups who
were being incarcerated and established
racialized municipal chain gangs and
convict leasing nearly a generation
before the end of slavery
and so let's talk about that moment at
the end of slavery and let's clarify a
few terms that i think are helpful if
they've not already been made clear in
the context of previous discussions
we talk a lot about mass incarceration i
use the term racial criminalization
and i want to introduce a concept of
mass criminalization that may be less
familiar and in this way racial
criminalization is simply defining or
stigmatizing a racial group of people as
criminal regardless of guilt or
innocence of course there's a little bit
of
double use of the term racial here but
the point being that a racialized group
of people
can then with
the power of description be defined as
criminal and it doesn't matter
individual behavior it is a form of
collective guilt
mass criminalization and that that is
using law and policy to limit the
freedom of a group of people regardless
of innocence and so here we move into
um what we will learn
more quickly
is one thing to assign a stereotype to a
group of people it is another thing to
use the force of the law to act on that
stereotype and then finally mass
incarceration and this is an important
distinction because mass criminalization
does not by definition lead to mass
incarceration indeed what we'll learn in
just a moment or what you likely already
know is that the era of convict leasing
in the south and the era of all white
juries after the passage of the 14th
amendment um is a period of mass
criminalization that the law is intended
as a form of
racial control or social coercion within
a political economy of punishment the
point is that people will accept their
second-class citizenship or they will
accept the coercive regimes of
sharecropping or tenant farming or other
forms of extractive work having little
to do
with putting as many people behind bars
where
we're talking about in the mid to late
19th century in fact
the infrastructure of the jail itself
was less substantial than was the prison
farm
or the private lease
but most people simply didn't serve time
at all they were scared into accepting
their second class lives working as free
labor
on a cotton farm or cotton plantation
and so of course the 13th amendment
which has come into lots of scrutiny
both for activists calling for new
amendments to strike the cause the
clause of punishment for crime but also
some scholarly scrutiny uh for the
a question of whether the
uh
congressional congress or the radical
republicans intended um to make the 13th
amendment a kind of hollow gesture
nowhere in my work have i
ascribed that intentionality to the 13th
amendment
although i don't write about it it
certainly acknowledged that this kind of
legal language or legal loophole
for forms of social and civil death had
been key to the notion of hard work as a
form of punishment and labor
even when prisons were racially
disparate in the opposite direction in
the early 19th century
where they were simply all white prisons
uh but that doesn't change the fact that
in the context of the south and the
post-vellum period southerners made
quite creative use
of this loophole for their own purposes
um and enshrined in a set of laws uh
known as black codes that african
americans would be subjected to an
entire body of of legal jurisprudence
that would be at its core anti-black and
intended to be so
the context of this is also a kind of
political revolution that brought with
it new justification for ideas these
ideas are very important because the
interplay of the use of
various forms of
coercive
criminal justice practices including the
leasing of people
to private industry or the threat of
punishment as such
also
was led to a narrative
of blackness that quickly attached to
new forms of data essentially to make
the case
but i wanted to highlight here that
the description of criminality is a new
form of justifying oppression
is also the ongoing control over power
the control over the power of political
representation and participation which
of course would come with citizenship
and eventually be legislated by virtue
of needing to pass and another amendment
that is the 15th amendment and here we
just hear the voice of one of the key
writers of this period hinton rowan
helper essentially warning the nation of
what happens if black people get to vote
and that their criminality is the basis
for that just disband transmit and that
distrust negroes with their crime
staying blackness could not rise to a
plane any higher than that of base and
beast-like savagery
helper presented his collection of
expert opinions as an archaeologist uses
fossils
to reconstruct some prehistoric creature
for the world to behold with gratitude
that it no longer walks the earth in
helper's case the caption for posterity
read terrible things await a nation bent
on handing ballots to beasts seeing then
that the negro does indeed belong to a
lower and inferior order of beings why
in the name of heaven why he pleaded
with his reader should we forever
degrade and disgrace both ourselves and
our posterity by entering of our own
volition into more intimate relations
with him may god in his restraining
mercy forbid that we should ever do this
most foul and wicked things now i know
you've read chapter two this comes from
chapter one
but it helps
to establish the baseline for the ways
in which the notion of savagery also led
to
extra legal violence and so if in the
context of the post spelling period if
in the context for an explosion of the
use of the criminal justice machinery or
as kelly lydon hernandez has already
suggested to us the infrastructure of
the jail as a coercive instrument so too
were forms of racial terror and here is
just one slice of looking at documented
cases of lynchings across multiple
states this number continues to change
as researchers continue to find new
examples the range of course many people
now know was very arbitrary uh acts of
transgressing the social norms of white
supremacy in the south
because as much as the exploitative
regime of sharecropping was intended to
use the threat of punishment to coerce
people um it also was wrapped in the
notion
that people's own dignity was a threat
to those forms of oppression that's the
simple fact of uh communicating across
the color line uh walking with one's
back in dignity wearing a uniform uh of
world war one uh extended the range of
the kinds of things police
initially
and so when
we began to accumulate um not just the
evidence of racial terror which often
was read as evidence of a black
transgression or a crime committed by a
black person and in the most extreme
examples uh used to justify uh lynching
uh was the accusation of rape of a black
male rape of white women and so we began
to produce statistical evidence out of
what today we call
criminal justice contact police contact
convictions arrests these sorts of
things and so now with the distance of
hindsight no one within the sound of my
voice would likely say well
of course that was all objective
state activity
and therefore the numbers were a helpful
guide to understanding the levels of
anti-social behavior within the black
community
but i'd caution you
to so easily judge those who articulated
this point of view in the past because
it's precisely the durability of this
notion that crime statistics have a kind
of truth value
to them that has helped not only to
justify the way that the south first and
then
really at a national scale organized
around these issues and even saying the
south first is complicated because the
treatment of antebellum african
americans as a criminal class even
preceded the postponed period but at
scale and within the context of national
debates about the relative fitness of
black people for citizenship
we first get to mass emancipation in the
period after the civil war and then new
kinds of tools that take place new kinds
of demographic questions and concerns
this is the heyday of eugenics
population studies are happening in the
western world uh in part to figure out
how to manage and contain uh the
movement and the aspirations of the
global south as we would recognize it
today
and so nathaniel schaeler happens to be
a popular riser of history a person
who's writing for the atlantic monthly
the same magazine
that exists today with the same kind of
approach and tone which is to kind of
bridge the gap between
social science and policy and you know
important questions that people are
trying to answer with empirical data for
popular audiences and so as a harvard
paleontologist he was a naturalist he
had no particular skill set for this
kind of work but took it on as a
translator
and in his first article on this topic
he essentially turned to statistics as a
way to resolve a kind of problem and
that problem was articulated by helper
which was to say that
many people
assumed that southerners had a kind of
bias towards ascribing criminality and
other uh racist stereotypes about black
people that they were primitive and that
in the position of being free they were
retrograding to their quote-unquote
ancestral condition
um
you know i don't want to get too much
into the present right now but just
simply to say uh that northerners had
the reputation of being sympathetic uh
to black people
and in the post-bellum period these
sectional divisions about
whose knowledge was most authoritative
on this question of the appropriate
place that black people would fit in the
social and political hierarchy of the
nation
came to be resolved by new forms of data
and i'm
dwelling on this point for just a moment
longer because it's precisely the
eugenics period
where the notion of objective crime data
or iq test or birth rates could all be
forms of knowledge production that would
help policy makers and elected officials
and other decision makers
to make sure that they organize society
the most productive and efficient way
and so out of the statistical data that
nathaniel schaeler was calling for it
came
the first turn towards
the u.s census in 1990. this census is
an important milestone because it
represented a perfect generational
cohort
for
looking at the
health and welfare of african americans
who had been born
outside of slavery so if you're born in
1866
for example
or in the winter of 1865
you've never quote unquote been touched
by slavery
and you could essentially compare
the health mortality morbidity
crime rates of people who had never been
enslaved to those who had had been this
kind of comparison didn't actually
happen in the way that i've described
but general claims did occur
meaning that
people took to the 1890 census as the
first authoritative census after the
civil war one sampling techniques were
problematic in 1877.
um there was now but the famous writer
thomas dixon page who was the novelist
whose work the klansmen became the basis
of birth of a nation he and others
called the new issue and the new issue
was a younger generation of black people
remember someone like w.e.b du bois is
born in great barrington massachusetts
in 1868 he represents the new issue he
represents a person who sees the
possibilities of his full
humanity as being unchecked and
undiminished by
claims of white supremacy and
essentially this animates his entire
life in corpus of academic work
the other new issue of course is all
those
entrepreneurial entrepreneurial and
aspiring black
freedom and people uh in the south and
challenging again the norms of white
supremacy of which we saw the reaction
uh both uh being defined as criminal and
sometimes literally being lynched by a
lynch mob
and so the 1890 census produces um
this new source of administrative
data that
points to a snapshot in time
that the population of african-americans
is now 12
but they represent 30 of those uh that
could be counted uh as prisoners the raw
numbers are roughly eighty two thousand
total prisoners of which black people
are about twenty two thousand within the
twenty two thousand about ninety percent
of them are men
now
because this is a critique of these data
the point is not to dwell on those
particular statistics uh to check their
veracity it didn't really matter because
people who turned to those statistics um
for the first time who made use of those
statistics who saw themselves as
innovative in an effort to pick up where
nathaniel shaler had left off by calling
for statistics as a way of measuring the
true racial capacity of black people
one of those figures was a man named
frederick hoffman
and in his work race trace and
tendencies which is really a work about
health differences and health outcomes
because in his day job as an actuary as
the leading actuary for prudential
insurance
his job was to make predictions about
life and death so that insurance
policies could be priced accordingly
he also had a particular uh
concern about
making sure that working class
white people including immigrants like
himself he was a german immigrant
would get a fair deal because he
recognized that both nativism and
segregation of
limited housing opportunities limited
mobility various forms of
state-sponsored discrimination directed
towards immigrant populations
was causing a problem for them
and hoffen's innovation in this moment
is to single out african americans
um to lift them out of what might have
been and i'm not arguing account of
factual simply arguing that the debate
that emerges around hoffman's work what
might have been
a
robust sociological or ecological
argument
about the nature of premature death in
the modern city
what essentially he wanted to say was
that many immigrants are suffering from
exogenous social forces
but black people are not
and to make his point he made a what we
call a white supremacist argument today
he he essentially argued that black
people by dent of behavior and biology
faced only two options in the
race of competition with white people
that is the avenue
a road to prison or to an early grave
and he was using the data i just showed
you of the disproportionate
representation of black people in prison
as evidence for it now of course you
know
that the political economy of punishment
which we've already established makes it
nearly impossible
to know how many black people were truly
quote unquote guilty of a crime and
deserving of punishment what we do know
is that
generalized notions of the
structural forces contributing to crime
was an increasingly popular point of
view
pushing back against eugenics claims and
so here hoffman himself clearly clearly
positions himself as someone interested
in
progressive solutions to the problem of
crime uh in other forms of antisocial or
community based harm he writes four
years before race traits and tendencies
of the american negro the study of
statistics of suicide madness and crime
is one of the utmost importance to any
society when such an increase has been
proved to exist as the duty of society
to leave nothing undone until the evil
has been checked or been brought under
control
that little must combo the wealthy
people we must be far from supplies as
long as we permit to exist or accept
inevitable conditions which year after
year drive increasing army of
unfortunate to madness crime or suicide
it is the struggle of the masses against
the classes i like to joke that if
if bernie sanders needed a speech writer
to illustrate the
excesses of capitalism and the harm that
it does to people
this metaphor of an increasing army of
unfortunate would would resonate very
powerfully with concern about the
premature death of white people
suffering from
both
deindustrialization and the opioid
crisis
so um hoffman was not alone there were
others such as the uh socialist and
progressive labour party member harry
reuben writing in the same magazine also
before race traits uh in an article
called crime and the enforcement of law
that the whole problem of crime as today
expressed in society is summed up in the
problem of poverty we have churches
enough schools enough moral sentiment
enough to regenerate the world in a
decade work not for the awful pressure
brought to bear on nine tenths of the
human race which all but forces them to
be vicious
and so i want to establish a clear line
that in hoffman's own formulation of the
use of crime statistics we have two
divergent explanations
that the data of the over-representation
of people in criminality when applied to
white people and european immigrants in
particular represents the evidence of
social forces of the structural economy
of the excesses of capitalism which is
why these people are self-identified as
socialist and progressives who share
this point of view in common
but hoffman argued just the opposite for
african americans because as a racist
and racialist project hoffman pursued
the data to make the argument or should
say to make the data fit the argument
here he notes prison and race statistics
from chicago philadelphia louisville and
charleston and from states including new
jersey and pennsylvania confirmed the
census data show without exception that
the criminality of the negro exceeds
that of any other race of any numerical
importance in the country so let's just
take that first part of the statement at
face value it is true that
that the evidence of the
disproportionate
participation in the criminal justice
system at the arrest level and in the
confinement level show the highest rate
of disproportionality
but if we were to take the same logic as
has been applied to various white
communities not by the eugenicists but
by the progressives and socialists we
say those are the people suffering most
from the structural disadvantages that
happen in society but instead hoffman
said just the opposite when the negro
learns to respect life property and
chastity until he learns to believe in
the value of a personal morality
operating in his daily life the criminal
tendencies will increase
and so this notion of black criminality
or racial criminalization
then happening in in massive form
um takes on a life of its own
and uh to use a concept developed by uh
barbara fields called racecraft
essentially the notion that
new
logics new racial logics or ideologies
of race are grafted onto ongoing
projects of uh of racial control and
power
and so in here the case is the degree to
which black people are pursuing
educational opportunities becomes an
argument against their further education
there is essentially all sorts of
magical thinking happening here which is
why i love this concept of racecraft
that barbara fields comes up with uh but
here's an example
the mississippi governor james k
vardaman who is one of 11 confederate uh
governors with former confederate states
and uh makes no minces no words about
the degeneracy and inferiority of black
people this is not a not a nuanced
circumstance but what's fascinating here
is he does in fact
feel the pressure to defend the
um what is happening in mississippi on
the basis of crime statistics and so as
much as there is a robust
muscular
white supremacy happening on the ground
there is still
this growing
appetite and need for a kind of national
agreement that southerners may not be so
bad after all if they can all agree that
the crime statistics tell the story and
so here governor bartoman says to school
the negroes to increase his criminality
official statistics do not lie and they
tell us that the negroes who can read
and write are more criminal than the
illiterate in new england where they are
best educated they are four and a half
times as criminal
as in the black belt where they are most
ignorant the more money for negro
education the more negro crime this is
the unmistakable showing of the united
states census so i want to disrupt the
easy way with which we might um throw
the governor into a bucket of
resignation because even the governor
wanted respect uh he wanted this form of
propaganda to be heard as a way of
justifying um
policies that were meant to be um
modern and
uh future oriented and not like his
pro-slavery slavery
ancestors in the same way that we
learned a lot about in international
comparisons about the ways in which
uh 20th century forms of segregation and
colonization are drawing on new ideas or
at least
ideas that are newly ascendant
and so
the black sociologist kelly miller who's
at howard university at the time uh it
takes this argument on directly as does
du bois in the study of the negro
problem uh where he points out hoffman's
biases by showing that there is an
appetite within the nation to accept
without criticism uh these early
pronunciations of black people as
forever doomed to be criminal i'll talk
a little bit more about that in another
example but here kelly miller takes on
this exact argument at face value he
says okay here's the argument where
legal processes are acknowledged to be
fair that is in the north in new england
for example where the negro has the
fullest educational opportunity which
was more like fuller rather than full
list
he shows a criminal rate three to four
times as great as his ignorant and
oppressed brother in the south and the
conclusion is hastily reached that
education makes the negro a criminal
which of course is a justification for
rolling back educational opportunity so
kelly miller then goes on to say well
okay if black men are five times more
likely in the state of massachusetts to
serve time than in mississippi maybe uh
hoffman and others are on to something
but what if white men are 10 times
overrepresented which it turns out to be
the case and so he asks this question
did education make northern white's
criminals too
or shall we foster the bliss of
ignorance only when it is found under a
black skin
as you know from your reading to bois
takes on similar arguments by pointing
out in various european cities
across from munich to breslau to other
places rates of quote-unquote
illegitimacy and prostitution are higher
than is true for black women you also
know that as much as hoffman
places his target on the backs of black
men
he also
uses illegitimacy rates and the sexual
transmission of venereal diseases as
evidence essentially the statistical
equivalent for black women as sexually
degenerate
and so these swirl of arguments of crime
rates and legitimacy rates
contribute to
what is happening on the ground in
cities across the country in atlanta
race riot emerges in 1906 a french
journal captures the scene in this
illustration
and what comes out of that is a powerful
example
born out of the work of ida b wells from
your reading you know addie b wells uh
witnesses the uh the lynching um of
three of her friends who run a grocery
store out of that she commits herself to
defending their
honor and to challenging the racial
terror of her
hometown memphis tennessee
because she used her printing press to
tell the their stories uh her printing
press is
ultimately burned down and she leaves
town one step ahead of a lynch mob she
lands first in philadelphia onto chicago
where she will dedicate the rest of her
life not only exposing the lies of white
supremacy but building an infrastructure
of social service and political activism
for black women in the club women's
movement uh she's an early founder of
the national association of color women
so on and so forth so she's got this
incredible career
but she takes on uh these arguments
about lynching because having born
direct witness to
its toll on black people
she
is one of the first
african americans who are challenging
the
the use of crime statistics to make an
argument about black inferiority in this
example she happens to be at a at a
fundraising dinner in chicago where
speaker has just talked about the recent
events in atlanta and a black woman i'm
sorry a white woman named mary plummer
who's a suffragist leans over to her and
says i don't know what we can say about
this terrible affair but there is one
thing i can say and that is to urge all
of you to drive the criminals out from
among you have you forgotten that ten
percent of all the crimes committed in
chicago last year were by colored men
less than three percent of the
population it's a remarkable moment
because it it shows that the
disproportionate
evidence of criminal justice contact for
black people becomes a justification for
the instrumental use of racial terror
and violence
two things can be true at the same time
never mind the fact that we can't trust
that there isn't bias in uh the
of larger
americans uh in chicago at this time
period which we'll talk about in just a
few moments and so within the body of
work that ida b wells is involved in her
most similar work southern horus which
you've also read
is a fascinating um example that at no
point in these histories that we are
telling did uh black people not speak
back to
uh the ideologies and the behavior
that
contributed to
premature death and the justification of
it
and so
in this study she she does a sample of
chicago tribune she reads them as you
well know i liken her approach here a
form of investigative journalism like
the washington post or the guardian
keeping track uh police killings because
the nation is not keeping track of it
and so she wants to to
uncover the myth of black men as rapists
as justifications for lynching which you
also know in your reading of frederick
hoffman
simply counted every lynching as
evidence of a black rape which by his
own standards actuary standards simply
wouldn't hold up to peer review so to
speak but nevertheless uh iwl says in
the preamble of this work that out of
their mouth shall be murder shall
murderers be condemned and she goes on
to debunk the rape myth um now of course
my colleague crystal feinster at yale
has done wonderful work in pointing out
that this rape myth is as much a form of
sexual control over the behavior of
white women um and so we have to think
about the gendered implications of white
supremacy both as directed towards black
women but as well that this myth also
functioned
as a form of
sexual and social control over white
women's sexuality as well
she debunks a myth by noting that only
31
of even the allegation in those
newspapers was of rape
and she also goes on to debunk the myth
of black female licentiousness
in this way she inverts a racial
narrative by reporting on white male
rape of black women and among the many
stories that she tells she tells one in
particular of a nashville man named pat
hanafan who had outraged a little
colored girl and for his crime he was in
fact sentenced to six months in the city
jail but upon release became a city
detective and this is not just
our
2021 sense of outrage at the hypocrisy
in this the story is in her book in 1892
precisely because she understood it as
outrageous as well nathaniel schaeler
who was a self-described friend of the
negro a liberal at the time
who essentially asked this statistical
question in 1890 which said a lot of
this in motion a decade later starts to
evaluate the evidence that's come in and
he takes a much more centrist moderate
view that perhaps even out of the work
of ida b wells he was inclined to
believe that the problem of rape on the
whole was more a problem of white male
rape than blackmail rape noting there is
less danger to be apprehended from them
in this regard than from an equal body
of whites of the like social grade
and so within this constellation
i want to turn our attention uh to for a
few minutes how this moves so this is
material that comes from chapter three
not out of chapter two
um because the continuation of the story
of hoffman's impact on setting the terms
of how to judge black people's fitness
for citizenship is also borne out by the
legacy of hoffman and others in pointing
to
european immigrants and low-income white
people as being worthy of citizenship
because their crime was not
disqualifying
and in this way studies like this of
frederick bushy on ethnic factors and
population of boston highlight the
criminality of the irish and italians
there's a moral degradation among irish
families for quarrels which are series
of fair for flashes of anger which mean
the knife thrust must go to the italian
quarters these are uh both expressions
of the kind of
racialized logics that apply to european
immigrants but these are arguments in
favor not of further criminalization but
of assimilation which is itself a form
of violence but within this context the
point is not to be punitive but to
incorporate people uh through fair
distribution of public goods
and so people make the argument that
these are americans in process these are
fellow passengers on our ship of state
hoffman himself engaged on this point um
but again his agenda was to single out
black people as exceptional
by comparison to the irish and
exceptional um lee worthy of divestment
and not investment um du bois as you
know from your reading went to great
lengths to expose the hypocrisies and
contradictions of hoffman's work and the
body of work that came from it he was
roundly and consistently dismissed as
being biased towards his own people
including university pennsylvania
sociologists saying that race had a chip
on his shoulder because surely his
accomplishments were evidence not of
white supremacy but of opportunity in
the country pretty remarkable and so
here du bois who's frustrated by a
decade after writing the philadelphia
negro in an essay called the souls of
white folks
very expressively describes the
circumstances of this contradiction
murder may swagger theft may rule
prostitution flourish and the nation
gives but specimatic intermittent and
lukewarm attention but let the murderer
be black or the thief brown and the
righteousness of indignation sweeps the
world it is blackness that is condemned
and not crime if it isn't obvious that's
where the title of the book comes from
others looked at these contradictions
and begin to give voice to them here's
an editorial from the naacp
pointing out as i like to say
the two men the white man to the left of
the
natalie dressed man as well as the black
man to the right of his counterpart are
our
equivalent of people sagging in the
early 20th century these are people who
are marked by
by a class identity within their race
which makes them suspect
and the point here in american logic is
that white people see this as individual
failure whereas american logic white
people see
a black man
whose class position
makes him proximate to criminality as
evidence of the race which is racial
criminalization if they had that
language at the time that's what they
would have called this
and so that logic leads to a predictable
outcome on the ground in the work of
progressives so the set of ideas to
justify reading crime statistics as
evidence of social economic and
political inequality then leads to
arguments such as this and this
illustration from a prisoner re-entry
organization in chicago describes the
scene of a
of a of a mother raising her children
potentially alone if not clear if her
husband is is in prison or down the
street or absent all together what we do
see is that she has five kids she's got
a lot of babies and so within the
context of eugenic concerns
she shouldn't have had all those babies
in the first place but for progressives
the problem here is that she lives in a
community of poor people with broken
windows
and that leads to juvenile delinquency
as two kids are fighting in the street
uh every poor uh community or immigrant
slum in the early 20th century in place
like chicago also has some kind of
saloon or bar around the corner it's
hard to see in this image but it's the
sign here where my mouse is and of
course every bad neighborhood then and
now has some you know over
uh population of police activity uh and
here some cop is dragging some guy off
the street
but rather than make this a call about
personal responsibility or chastity and
morality as hoffman did these
progressives in chicago made this an
issue
about a larger structure so long as
there are bad tenements sweatshops
brutal policemen bad jails child labor
dishonesty grinding employers saloons
and gambling dents as long as boys are
taught to fight and allowed to carry
firearms so long as fathers are in
different deserts and mothers must
maintain the family by the washboard so
loan crime will continue what will you
do to help this association to prevent
it
and this story plays out time and time
again jane addams is the leading social
worker of the period
she has tremendous power and influence
as a middle class
white woman social reformer she writes
several books she redefines the problem
of community harm and juvenile
delinquency and
social dysfunction
not just as a problem of society and the
mistreatment of views but also not as
one that is attached to immigrant status
or even attached to
uh nationality she is decriminalizing
and de-racializing the problem of white
youth criminality because the statistics
she's facing um are overwhelming 15 000
youth brought before the juvenile court
in 1904 she's talking about white kids
she describes them as stealing from
their parents swiping junk pawning their
clothes and shoes
doing quote any desperate thing to get
the dope as they called it she describes
daily acts of violence of interpersonal
violence as was true in the case of
this example of people using firearms so
you know the point is i'm showing you
the primary evidence upon which we can
see up close how this is playing out and
she also argues that so a polish youth
shot an irish boy in the head this tale
could be duplicated almost every morning
what might be merely a boy's scrap is
turned into a tragedy because some boy
has a revolver and she adds we certainly
cannot expect the fathers and mothers
who have come to the city from farms or
have immigrated from other lands to
appreciate or rectify these dangers nor
could we expect the young people
themselves to kill the cancer of modern
city conditions this is jane adams is an
entire corpus of work and that corpus of
work is also echoed by the university of
chicago
in its ecological approach which saw
immigrant criminality and poverty or
immigrant crime and poverty as evidence
both of my groups and the solution to
that was to disperse them uh into
communities with greater opportunity to
lift up their economic base uh and to
engage in various forms of
police reform and other things
um her work was praised for being even
poetic
within the bounds of sociology which
would be a rare thing today
but of course
people do win pulitzer prizes which i
guess is kind of the equivalent for
writing a great work of ethnography
such as matt desmond so on and so forth
just to illustrate very quickly these
politics of knowledge
and the violence of racial
quantification are also
showing up in black
conservative voices
booker 2 washington is one expression of
this
perhaps not as harsh as this one this is
a man named william hannibal thomas who
you also were introduced to from your
reading
he says that he's writing to
sociologists in the country because he
has first-hand experience of what he's
seen and as a black man he can testify
with certainty that that it is true
black people um are degrading into a
savage behavior they are savage at heart
unable practically to discern between
right and wrong intrinsically inferior
type of humanity a record of lawless
existence led by every impulsive passion
really the inferiority of the negro and
mind morals judgment and character such
that there is no doubt that some very
plausible confirmatory evidence of the
justice of the simian theory of human
origin might be derived from a close
inspection of his demeanor that's a
mouthful but he basically said that he's
convinced black people really are closer
to apes and monkeys
than they are to human beings of course
he wrote this around the same time as a
young man named oda benga from the congo
literally placed in the bronx zoo on
display uh in the animal kate in the
monkey cage
so that uh hannibal thomas actually did
not present the kind of statistical
evidence that one could uh expect of
such claims in the way that both hoffman
used them and even
james k bartoman the mississippi
governor is
surprising because one would have
expected that his book would have simply
been ignored by academics but it wasn't
in fact by
franklin giddings a towering
intellectual within the social science
community the founder of columbia
university sociology department and the
third president of the american
sociological association praised uh
william hannibal thomas's book as a
sociological study it is one of the most
valuable things to be put in the hands
of genuine students of american
conditions that i know of presented
subject without an atom of the
sentimentality which is so often proved
a blemish in many books otherwise most
excellent
so we've just seen an example where one
is praised in the case of jane adams for
sentimentality and yet hoffman a black
man who is written without any of the
structural rules of social science is
praise for being objective because he is
a member of the race new york times also
gave it a rave review
and so to close um the echo of this
moment um leads to
what
will continue to be
various forms of
redlining of instrumental violence of
police control and eventually police
taking on the work of maintaining the
second class and segregated lives of
black people outside of the south this
is a scene from the chicago race riot i
won't dwell on it we can talk more about
it in q a
black people in defense of themselves
are searched and stopped
and disarmed
out of that report came a number of
recommendations these recommendations i
won't read in this instance other than
to say that
they recommend it led by a black
sociologist from the university of
chicago the crime statistics themselves
ought to be jettisoned because they were
overly biased and were giving a bad or
false information evidence of their
inaccuracy and misrepresentation and a
leading criminologist agreed in two
additions uh that they were these
statistics were completely unreliable
i'm going to skip over this example in
the interest of time we can come back to
it so we could ask the question what
happened to bushi's italian
and irish criminals how many italian
americans committed armed robbery last
year irish american burglars
or
in this case
we can't know right the answer is that
those statistics disappeared
the fact of their disappearance is the
evidence of
the way that this
use of crime statistics as professor
stanley would describe as a form of
propaganda
continues to drive discussion and debate
about the fate and future of black
people
edwin sutherland noted that one of the
reasons why they stopped counting the
irish and italian-americans is because
they appear to approach the same kind of
behavior as white americans native-born
which is to essentially say as long as
black people could be singled out or
mexicans or chinese americans or chinese
immigrants for having excessive crime
rates it did
make the crime and just to show you this
is crystallized in uniform crime reports
which to this day are the most
authoritative form of arrest statistics
as an indicy of crime in the nation in
1933 when they began they pointed out
negroes and the foreign born should be
watched by 1940 it is significant to
point out that the figure for native
whites includes the immediate
descendants of foreign-born individuals
this is a form of statistical white
flight at precisely the moment where
white flight is in fact beginning to
happen in parts of the country
the kerner commission picks up on the
same recommendations as the chicago
report which is why i didn't read those
in interest of time but they essentially
amount to
better treatment of citizens more police
protection because one of the other
sides of the coin of racist policing is
also under protection they call for
independent citizen review boards a stop
to aggressive patrol develop community
policing a lot of this to sound familiar
so familiar that even for
kenneth clark who was famous for having
done doll studies and contributing to
the end of formal segregation in the 54
supreme court decision on brown versus
board of education notes that he read
the chicago riot report he read another
one in harlem in 1935 another one in
1943 and that added that he kept reading
the same recommendations and that it
must be a kind of alice in wonderland
with the same moving picture we've shown
over and over again same analysis same
recommendations and same in action
and so here we are with bloomberg and
comstat um
the over representation of black and
latinos relative to white in the era of
mass incarceration the ongoing use of
violent crime rates the notion here is
that because crime dropped incarceration
must work um you see an inverse
relationship with stop and frisk this
was the defense of stop and frisk as a
massive system of racial control and
police discrimination that was
ultimately ruled as such in 2013
and what i wanted to show you here is
what collective guilt looks like because
the long legacy of frederick douglass is
articulated by the former police
commissioner
in
new york ray kelly who knows it doesn't
mean that people are not doing anything
wrong to the question of stop infringe
racial profiling if you look at the
statute it says reasonable suspicion
that individuals might be about to
commit a crime there's a preventative
aspect to this people say innocent that
is not the appropriate word that's what
collective guilt looks like and then he
notes this is standard law enforcement
practice around america
i won't dwell on this but this comes
back to the same kinds of infrastructure
of criminality that we saw in kelly
lytle's work drunkenness disorderly
conduct public urination
the scale of latino and black stops
produced little more than summonses when
people were stopped but 90 weren't even
issued so much as summonses because the
vast majority of people were stopped for
things that were not in fact crimes
ferguson had the same problem we know
from the result they resorted to racist
ideas to justify it and so i'm reminded
when we come back to the racial terror
era of lynching that when we look at
police consent decrees since 1995 there
are about 70 of them this is just a
partial list it kind of looks the same
right it looks like how we might look
back on this moment and see uh the same
tally
of state violence in this moment as
similar to state violence in the
lynching era which of course in the
lynching era was defensible and yet
we're still having a debate about the
defensibility of state violence in this
moment
um
and so i close with one final echo and
that echo is uh that we could read the
evidence of opioid death in the nation
uh in this kind of data visualization
that the new york times did a few years
ago
with the evidence of wide-scale death
not too much of a leap
to note that that death itself is
wrapped up in various forms of illegal
drug consumption and distribution and
related crimes that go along with it and
yet we are to understand as a society
that this tally of death in white
america is evidence of a public health
challenge and chris christie articulates
this quite clearly addiction is an
illness we can beat if we give the
people the tools and support they need
to overcome this disease if we choose to
free people from the stigma of addiction
recognizes the public health challenge
it truly is we can help people to
reclaim their lives think army of great
a great army of unfortunate we can find
the true measure of our compassion the
investment we're making will change
lives and get more people into treatment
earlier
instead of the emergency room or prison
later so this is a call for disrupting
the social conditions leading to
premature death in white america and
with that thank you so much for uh
for following that alone look forward to
conversation
thank you so much khalil and i loved
your adding new york times also gave it
a rave review
history does not change uh
so uh so tim uh do you want so first of
all i want to say everyone place your
questions into the q a uh and uh i will
start uh
collecting the questions and we'll
moderate them uh as they start to roll
in um
so uh
so
let's uh let's begin tim do you have
i mean i i had a thought khalil that i'd
like to share with you and and see if if
you if if you've had a similar thought
in in your book
you raised the tantalizing possibility
which we can't know you know whether
frederick hoffman had read
id wells
and whether in some sense he was
responding to her
and i i in reading these two primary
readings which jason assigned along with
your book
i i was struck
by by by really strange structural
similarity
that led me to think of what
hoffman was doing as a kind of like
scientific lynching
and i the reason i'm thinking about this
are two elements that i draw from ida b
wells
the the first is
she points out
that what a lynch mob is doing
is
basically discrediting the state
lynch mob is saying these people don't
deserve the law
and
a bit by saying that you're basically
pushing the state out of the picture
right you're pushing the rule of law out
of the picture in the conventional sense
and the other thing she's doing which is
which seems rather you know courageous
or was courageous is that she's drawing
attention to the the gender or the
sexual
aspect of it right
and then if you read you know
if you read the whole hoffman thing
you can look at what he's doing as this
as as as kind of the same thing that
she's criticizing but unlike a much more
you know
in this empiricist way in a scholarly
way because he's arguing you know not
like a lynch mob would say one black man
did something on the basis of hearsay or
you know rumor or whatever and he's
saying
the whole black race
does things
right and he's doing it on the basis of
this kind of sketchy reading of of
evidence but it's like it's the same
move and then there's the same
conclusion which is that these people
basically don't deserve the law
right they're outside the law you know
maybe the state should act to protect
other people but the state shouldn't act
to protect them and there's this weird
dichotomy which you which you emphasize
in your talk where you know
kaufman is basically saying the state
should be giving white people good
conditions for existence meanwhile it
should be social darwinism for for for
black people right this is this funny
thing but then there's also this gender
component too right i mean i d wells is
hinting not hinting hinting's you know
she's suggesting pretty openly that
there's an element of white male anxiety
about all this right
and you know and hoffman has an answer
to that he's saying look they're gonna
die out
right like they're not you know they're
they're not gonna they're gonna die out
and like that's
i mean and when he was saying that i was
thinking of like the performative part
some of the perform nasty or
performative parts of lynching right
like you're going right you're going
when you say that a race is going it's
going to die out you're also going
that's that's an organ about manhood
right i mean that's they're not going to
they can't keep it going right they're
going to die out so reading these things
together along with your you know with
your marvelous work i was struck by this
kind of odd structural similarity
between these between these uh but
between like between the way ivy wells
describes lynching and then the way that
hoffman goes about describing
crime well i think that's one of the
things that is
surprising
in examining du bois's work as well
dubois is stuck
trying to
essentially argue
against racialization by using the same
disparity data that everybody else is
using
he doesn't have any more evidence
than the same
sets of quote unquote facts
about disproportionate arrest rates in
in the city of philadelphia for example
except uh he has a different
interpretive lens for how to explain
what's happening to black people
so your point about the symmetry with
which these arguments are constructed
is is
partly why
this work is
this period is so important because
we're stuck
with the same form of the argument
about what to make of
you know this what i would call
statistical artifact right a statistical
artifact is a trace of a set of
interactions a set of power
relationships a set of events
and what to make of those events as you
point out rightly
iwells is seeing
all sorts of things that that as you
point out white male anxiety she's
seeing different forms of victimization
on different scales but essentially it's
this
is the evidence of either a lynching or
a rape
that that is the linchpin of the entire
uh discussion
um
um
i have a bunch of questions i'm gonna
try to hold them uh so uh uh tight so um
one of the um
let me see where to begin so first of
all um
is it right do i have it right from the
understanding of the policing literature
that one of the things they did in
response to irish and italian-american
crime was to make irish and
italian-americans police
um
that's one way to put it i think the
motivation wasn't to solve the crime
problem the motivation
was
um you know it was a it was a form of
distributing public goods and in this
case civil service jobs
the
let me just qualify that with one one
additional note um
in all of these groups in these
liminal transitional spaces between
being the target of policing to being
part of the police was usually a moment
when
some irish guy gets hired to then go be
um
like the special
forces guy for rooting out irish crime
or the italian guy who does the same i
mean this these histories are really
fascinating um because we can you know
i've forgotten the guy who was the
italian the first italian american who
infiltrated you know the sicilian mob in
new york city and then there's samuel
battle who's like the first black person
who's assigned to harlem so um there's a
little bit of truth to what you're
saying but that i think at scale it was
more about distributing civil service
jobs or which policing was one part of
it but did they do something similar
with black americans and
would they make them into police police
uh
like
yeah well this is this is why your
question uh why i answered your question
about political patronage and
opportunity structures rather than about
crime control because in the case of
italians and the irish um they moved
into these positions
what i'd say at scale
um whereas for black people they didn't
move into these positions at scale right
they they were tokens they were
you know a little bit of inside
intelligence for helping to solve
certain crimes but in some ways they
were a tiny sliver of patronage so we
never saw the same upward mobility as a
as a kind of form of political patronage
for black people that would have
positioned them to simply be the last
immigrants to join the force if we were
to use that metaphor
great um okay so uh so
two more quick questions and then and
then i will we'll uh uh
so one i just want to check my
my teaching of hoffman i regularly teach
hoffman just because i mean i i think it
probably holds the same fascination for
all of us the way the objectivity
he believes he's objective yet it's so
clearly uh you know i mean
you know
you it's helpful that hoffman sometimes
to remind yourself he's arguing that
black people have less vital force than
white people and you know you have to
remember there's no such thing as vital
force
so yeah so uh but this massive
statistics what you have the core of so
many hoffman's arguments are these
claims that in this context there's no
racism so so he says look in the north
we know there's no racism
in the south there's racism but in the
north we still have these disparities so
therefore so so it
these arguments of oh well this is a
group that doesn't of black people it
doesn't face anti-black racism that
seems to me core to
to racist arguments like
not seeing the effects of racism like
uh
now with the cove disparity in covet
deaths hoffman would quickly conclude oh
black people have less vital force they
have less but now no one people don't
make that error like well clearly that's
environmental um
well there there are still medical
scientists and researchers who are you
know literally still searching for the
the last remnants of dna that might
reveal the fundamental differences uh in
health outcomes so
the colloquial version of this is that
we're 99 the same and some people might
say 99.9 but damn it if that point one
percent won't tell the whole story
that's kind of how it works
and we see the same the same exact thing
with iq iq debate right we see the same
you know like people say oh black kids
adopted into white families
eventually
do have an iq deficit but they don't
face racism
because you know the assumption that
so so how so there's an echoing of
hoffman's arguments
uh in it throughout modern i was
wondering if you if you yeah i would
just
yeah yeah go on
yeah i was just going to say i mean one
of the things that as a writer i tried
to do um this might be a curiosity to
your students i mean i wrote about
hoffman uh as as someone who couldn't
you know i didn't my job wasn't to pass
judgment on hoffman um in analyzing his
text and and one of the ways that i
focused on doing that was to
write from the perspective of him
looking forward rather than us looking
backwards
and i give him a lot of credit for his
ingenuity and innovation and you know
his willingness his willingness to
defend his point of view and to search
for the evidence wherever it led him and
could find it um and i in a way that's
the boys project also i mean just to
come back to tim's earlier point i mean
du bois leaves philadelphia goes to
atlanta and spends a decade
turning over every stone he can to take
seriously maybe there is some evidence
that black people have a particular
predisposition to you know various kinds
of pathologies
he doesn't find it um and he gives up
and the only reason he gives up is
because the deck stacked against him his
arguments don't sit within a milieu
that is inclined to read any form of
black disadvantage or failure or death
as evidence that there's something wrong
with black people
um so to your point i mean the
climate in which academic research and
various debates about racial disparities
today animate a lot of academic research
um
and it tends to be a little bit more
disciplinary in terms of who's on what
side economists tend to be more on the
side of individual agency it's a science
of individual and rational choice so
that's not entirely a surprise and
sociologists tend to be uh more inclined
to take the structural argument but
there's you know
heterogeneity in both sides and
sociologists weren't always as open to
to these exogenous arguments about black
people
i'm just going to follow up we'll
quickly hand it over to tim and then
we'll go to questions
that's a great point because it brings
out it brings out the
uh the thing that's most critics one of
the things that's most criticized in the
current anti-critical race theory moral
panic which is you're impugning
objectivity and you've just brought out
brilliantly i mean i i once i once had a
facebook argument with glenn lowry who
was like
falling into this oh well there's
objectivity and neutrality and i was
like wait you know so economics doesn't
have an ideology and you know and he's
like oh yeah okay you're right like what
a discipline is is an ideology like as
you just
pointed out and and uh but this is all
being you know what's what's happening
this this point that that
any statistics any interpretation of
statistics is going to bring with it an
ideolo an ideologue
is going to be due to an ideological
lens is being attacked as an attack on
science and objectivity that's right
yeah
tim
i mean there's there's a dialectic there
which is similar to the dialectic i
wanted to mention before we before we
turn and the dialectic is
if you believe that you're the kind of
person who's always objective
that's a very deep form of subjectivity
right exactly yes and there are a lot of
folks in these in these debates who
think that they are the kind of people
who are always objective that's right
right which is a marker of their
subjectivity um i wanted to say
something similar about the law because
i was i was really struck
in in your presentation and the way you
went back and forth between the sources
and also in the iwells southern horrors
with an issue that i see when i when i
write about colonialism and actually
about nazi crime
which is this notion that
we as a people
are so legal
right we are such people of the law
that we can tell when it's okay to make
an exception right like we are so we are
by definition such legally minded people
that if we carry out a lynching
that prove that ipso facto that must
have been justified right that state of
exception must have been justified and
you see that you see that kind that
state of mind in in in with with the
germans in eastern europe i mean it's
very similar like this notion that we
are obviously of a higher legal status
than the people we confront
and because of our legal knowledge we
know that it's okay to make an exception
that's right we know because we're such
legal people we know which people are
outside of the law we know when we can
make an exception
yeah can i just uh echo that i mean i i
wanted to make that point in the in the
sort of preamble to the lecture
about the foundational lawlessness of
the law itself and and you know to
really nail the point of a white outlaw
culture embedded within a legal culture
that on the face of things
possible um you square these
contradictions um other than in the way
you just described and uh the perhaps
the more controversial analogy would be
that
white-collar crime and financial crimes
um in a
culture that we have today
is very much about rewarding people who
can break the law and get away with it
um and there's a kind of culture of
admiration and respect for it because if
everyone's playing by the rules and no
one's going to make any money because
the market is going to adjust perfectly
to perfect knowledge we all know the
same thing then we're all competing at
the same level but it's precisely the
moment at which i can exploit
information which is often illegal to
exploit that information uh that i can
get make money and you know maybe we
catch these people maybe we don't i
remember hearing a survey of
self-reported
crimes by financial sector elites saying
you know basically have you witnessed or
know of um a crime being committed
within the context of your work and i'm
just going to guess what i heard at that
moment and people can look it up but you
know it was a large number it was well
over 50 saying yes we've seen this all
the time
and that's just the point right the
rules are made to be broken by powerful
people only to reinforce that they're
the right people to be in control of the
law
excellent uh so um
i'm going to so we've got
a bunch of questions
one of them
feeds right into
the muhammad world view and one of them
is the question the main critique you
always get which one do you want to
start with let's start with the critique
okay so one of our students took
professor philip goff's course and uh on
and uh and they they're talking about
and of course
uh phil professor goff is a you know
statistics are going to be used and it
is uh so so this student wants to say
you know how do we grapple between with
attention
have you ever heard this question before
how do we grapple with the tension
between simply knowing racism as a truth
of our existence versus using statistics
as a way to prove our reality to those
who don't experience it that is white
people yeah so i think this is a
question saying um do we have to throw
the baby out with the bathwater right
well you know i don't have a good answer
for this question anymore than i had a
decade ago when i first wrote this book
what i can tell you is that other people
who study comparative societies
that are rooted in settler colonialism
or colonialism
uh south africa brazil um
france uh essentially tell stories uh or
have shown that in societies where there
is um little administrative or empirical
data to trace racial disparities
communities have had a harder time who
are the victims of systemic racism in
making the case for those experiences
and therefore
one could argue that
the
other side of the coin of racial
criminalization vis-a-vis crime
statistics has been
robust social movement activism
in defense of black people's civil and
human rights
essentially using the same evidence
against their oppressors
and i don't know
that i can solve for that history
anymore by acknowledging that
contradiction
but if the question is you know how do
we move forward seems to me that
that's less an answer about whether we
get rid of racial crime statistics as
some kind of early warning system
um and get ours to resocialize ourselves
um to a
more universal understanding of the very
outlaw culture that i've just described
um
to borrow tim's work here in a country
that has
you know used forms of memory laws to
prohibit um deep socialization and
learning about the things that we are
supposedly never to forget we keep
forgetting the same histories over and
over again and producing similar
outcomes in our society that to me seems
to be a first order problem before we
can decide whether or not
using race as a way of measuring social
phenomenon is no longer useful in our
society
good so okay now let's um flip
continuing on the
theme of objectivity um
so here's a question on the misuse and
weaponization of objectivity in modern
america
um
one of and there's another again a
student in our class uh we have a mix we
have a mixed audience of public and
students uh so uh so here the question
is uh
how do you think crime data is
weaponized and debates about policing in
major cities especially with regard to
increased use of algorithms and
widespread use of surveillance
technology okay that's a bit of a
softball down the
yeah yeah no it's a great it's a great
question and uh i wrote a new preface to
condemnation uh two years ago and um i
had thought i might read a little bit
from it but i didn't but essentially a
couple years ago by way of anecdote bill
bratton announced compstat 2.0 at a
conference that i was attending in new
york city it was a future of cities
conference hosted by the rockefeller
foundation
and he bragged about comstat 2.0 being
more predictive and not prejudicial more
discriminating and not discriminatory
because this new
algorithm of hot spot policing was going
to pinpoint exactly the right criminals
in the community sweep them away and
make communities safe again
and so he even jokingly said something
to the fact that it was like minority
report the tom cruise movie uh where
these precocks
short for precognition could predict the
future see a crime happen and then they
send
the police out tom cruise for example to
stop the murder before it happened and
so i i write in the preface that this
notion of a minority report as a film is
a double entendre upon on the notion of
a minority report focusing on on black
and brown people
so to answer your question
for much of policing today remains
committed
to
the
hyper surveillance of black communities
predicated on the notion that the
statistics show
that there's lots of crime in those
communities and therefore um policing
ought to uh remain at the levels that it
has historically been and ought to
be the primary instrument for delivering
public safety now
you didn't read this in the book and i
i
talked a bit about in the lecture for
for this obvious reason
that
if we are to take history potentially as
some guide
to what might be possible in the present
and people can disagree about whether
that can happen or not
policing was never the solution to all
the anti-social behavior in the white
community it's not now
and it wasn't then
after we got through with the eugenics
period and the period of nativist act
reaction to immigrants so the response
was social investment
so we seem to be stuck
on allowing law enforcement to define
its bureaucratic imperatives as our
moral imperatives
and therefore it's going to use its
evidence as best it can to make its
argument
which is to continue to point to crime
statistics as the proof
but aside from everything we might say
uh to comp to complicate what does a
crime actually mean in the social
context you use tommy's just tommy
shelby's work my colleague who makes a
very sophisticated argument that as a
philosopher essentially says we can't
judge the crime in the community if we
can't deal with the crimes of the state
um
and so uh anyway we could go down the
road there but that's that's my reaction
yeah
just just an aside it's just it's just
so incredibly
frustrating it undersells it to see this
repeat itself again and again professor
hinton's first book is on this topic the
removal of social she's speaking later
in the seminar we're reading both of her
books uh the removal of of social aid
and support and just criminal solutions
and again and again and again and again
the uh i won't ask you what people ask
me what's the solution
all right
so uh
um so uh
um so
so another question um
uh
one of the audience members is curious
about hoffman's
legacy in terms of the emphasis of uh on
of law and order and the war on crime uh
some 60 years later so now we are
getting attentions well could i could i
well unless there's an add on to that
question there is an interesting
footnote that isn't obvious from what
they read
oh go on yeah so very quickly uh hoffman
it couldn't be more interesting as a as
a writer so you know it might have been
good enough to to read this book to put
it in this historical context and to see
his contribution to the way that we have
this conversation today that's kind of
the that's the point of chapter two but
it turns out that hoffman is such a
seminal figure
that his study of homicide in the
country makes him a sole source
authority
on national homicide statistics until
the 1920s
it really is until the federal
need for nationalizing the collection of
crime data uh that hoffman is the number
one source
for
making claims about who's dying where in
what parts of the city uh and he's so
credited for it that uh he's a he's he's
award-winning so on and so forth but one
quick note
his longevity is so significant and his
his place in this
sort of social economy um is so
significant that the national urban
league a civil rights organization uh
invites him to a conference in the 1920s
to basically give the statistics on on
homicide in black america because that's
if you want to know who's dying and of
what he's the guy and
and du bois
um he's either there or gets wind of it
and he you know proverbially pulls his
hair out because he's like
this guy won't go away i cannot get rid
of him um so to you to the questioner's
point hoffman
lasts much longer than the 1890s when
this book is published in his
significance
so i noticed an aldon morris's book on a
scholar denied when he was describing du
bois's conferences in the atlanta
atlantic they looked a lot like year by
year responses to hoffman's book
is that right i mean do you know i i
don't like disease one is on yeah yeah i
mean i i would say um that a lot of
a lot of academics build their careers
frustrated with some body of work
right that they want to take down and
and i i don't think it's too much of a
stretch to say that hoffman was a
consummate foil for dubois right that
makes sense
um so so uh uh uh
uh right so so this um but to continue
the question
the person wanted you to draw uh
parallels between uh between the 1960s
the kind the the era
uh you know the the the uh the front
lash era as it were to borrow
vessel weaver's terminology uh and
hoffman um
so so how do you yeah yeah well i'll
just say that um and i'm gonna draw my
colleague former iu colleagues where
nicole siegel uh who's written a book
called violence work
and uh what's fascinating about that
work a rich archival study uh is to look
explicitly at the
relationship between
the academic community of criminologists
and
the
clinical practice of law enforcement and
that these two things bleed into each
other beginning in the 1960s and so
there's a kind of technocratic
uh consensus between a body of academic
research
and uh basic law enforcement that
there's no room for for for any critical
distance
essentially the academic community is a
handmaiden to
law enforcement's need they need them to
tell them you know how can we do do our
jobs better how can we be more effective
at this work and while this might not be
entirely a surprise
it neutralizes and mitigates the kinds
of critiques
that come from other academic pockets
and other kinds of research such that
law enforcement is not accountable any
they can point to the very research
community
that they are both getting funding from
the
from federal sources increasingly to do
this work and so
everybody in the way that hoffman is
can argue for empiricism
as the currency
for policy making that is fundamentally
discriminatory and uh is causing uh so
much social activism that of course uh
elizabeth is writing about in her second
book
uh
so um here's the next question also from
a seminar member um
uh given the perception that quote
education makes the black person a
criminal unquote how can we understand
the process of reformation within the
19th and 20th century prison systems
that's what we sort of we've been going
chronologically because uh it's a
history class and that's apparently how
you guys roll
um
but uh but so so we've been talking
about you know we've read foucault we've
we've talked about uh we started with
austin reed's uh book and uh we've been
looking at reformation uh so so so the
question is um
how does uh so there's moral reformation
through religion and physical
reformation
through work um
but uh how does how does this discussion
of
education
increase criminality play into prison
reformation discussion about
intellectual reformation in the late
19th and early 20th century is is the
result i guess you know to build on the
question is is the result that the
reformation discussions in prison and uh
in prisons in late 19th and early 20th
century exclude teaching include exclude
um prison i mean it's really interesting
because i'm tempted to go to the eras i
know in the 90s and removing prison
education you know uh which happened in
the 90s uh so uh you know as if that you
know was not as if education was not
important to reformation at all but is
that a theme that in in late 19th
earlier 20th century you know
was was educational intellectual
reformation
uh
frowned upon as a result of these
discussions so so let me cut to the
first argument or the first a bit of
evidence and then back into that
question so uh first of all what is
happening in the context of reformation
uh
does not apply to the vast majority of
african americans who are still
southerners in the late 19th and early
20th century
the prison scholars including rebecca
mclennan and others see
the
the broader period say between 1870 and
1920 as a progressive project in rebecca
mclennan words as a kind of effort of
manly citizenship but it is thoroughly
racialized in the direction of what is
required
to give white men a second chance
um through the incarceration experience
mostly that is about work so there is
still you know a carceral regime of
extraction from men
in the name of rehabilitation
but increasingly they get the kind of
programming that we would recognize in
more modern times they get
to publish newspapers they get you know
various forms of arts and entertainment
theater productions um
there isn't formal education that i'm
aware of and i've studied this period
pretty well uh in the way of people
getting geds for example
but anything's possible and so i don't
want to exclude that just because i
can't recall that being part of it so
there is a kind of uh
series of of kind of
intellectual nourishment that comes
through the arts in other kinds of
writing forums for people who are
publishing newsletters in these places
but these are these are places that
house
80 percent white populations there are
you know small numbers of uh
incarcerated people of color in chicago
new york philadelphia los angeles uh in
these early days um maybe not so much
los angeles let me let me hold off on
that precisely because of kelly's work
um but in the places that i've looked at
these histories that's what it looks
like
it's the south that is you know
literally the dark ages and
there's no effort to educate anybody so
what i point to in the presentation and
what you heard um has everything to do
with the larger justification for
at best a sharecropper's education in
the south uh because too much education
would give people the tools to question
society uh and therefore that was that
was not consistent with the uh racial
project of control right it's it's it's
kind of truly remarkable when we think
about in the what happened in nine in
the 90s when they removed
uh
funding for prison education uh
that that was the 1990s
well that was austerity right so that
was that was a version of neoliberalism
um
uh pointing to
uh punitiveness as a as a public good
um without encouraging uh forms of
dependency or
um
you know form of dependency and that is
for the state um and so you could invest
in more punishment um as a form of
incapacitation
and maybe the logic of deterrence uh
without making good on any other
possibilities like you know pulling pell
grants pulling programming for education
inside
okay so that's maybe we have time for
one more question let's see um
uh
so uh
so
uh
so we have a couple a couple more
questions about black education but i
think we've we've uh
uh
i mean
one general question
let me see what question to close on uh
well do you want to talk about the
legacy of um you know maybe tying some
of these themes together i'm just
jealously
ask you to end on this because i'm
really interested in and uh this whole
idea that uh that
um
you know
i'm interested in the
modern sort of race
um
[Music]
this this this stereotype that that
black people are black americans are
anti-education or view education um as
uh as as as white that the uh has been
disturbing me of late and i'm one so the
question was how does this legacy of
criminality and education fit into uh
have a bearing on contemporary
discussions of uh black people on
education
yeah um
well there are a lot of them but there's
one i skipped over in the presentation
so
in the interest of efficiency
of course is a major theme in in these
arguments right i am going i'm going to
show you something i skipped over
because i think it gets a little it gets
out a little bit of this so
there's a there's a section of the book
uh it's not in the chapter the students
read where
part of the rationale i mean part of the
emphasis of the book
and these
echoes
is that so much of
what we might easily dismiss as white
supremacy
required so much effort
at a performance of objectivity
people wanted to be taken seriously
people wanted
not to be dismissed as racist
and that tendency today to turn to
empirical evidence to end an argument to
resolve a debate is the same tendency to
say i'm not a racist
black people commit more crime than
anybody else it's a fact
right that's the way that that's the
structure of the debate
and so part of the structure of the
debate that we carry with us
is that people having this debate about
how to explain these disparities 100
years ago
was to then say okay
well maybe we should look if education
really works if education really
um
is just about opportunity and we just
need to extend more opportunity and that
will
be the answer to these disparities i'm
talking 100 years ago
then people started looking at the
criminal records of the alumni of
various schools hbcus
theodore roosevelt did it at hampton and
tuskegee as you know jason from having
read the book and it's remarkable
um
booker t washington writes an article
about it he basically saying you know
you can count the alumni of hbcus and
just a handful you know can be counted
in criminal records
um
and what's interesting is there's no
equivalency
that i ever found amongst various
immigrant populations that had shared
this similar container of
criminalization for a time
in fact i'm not the only one who pointed
out a guy named ray standard baker who
was a liberal progressive at a time they
wrote a book called along the color line
this was probably one of the more
progressive books that could kind of
point to a lot of contradictions it's
cited in condemnation and he pointed out
he said look you know we keep counting
like what happens to black people in
these schools
as some kind of evidence of whether or
not the school itself
is important or useful
when we don't do the same for places
like harvard and other places
and his point is that if we started to
keep track of the criminality coming out
of the mainstream elite white
institutions
and if we did an economic analysis of it
there would be untold damage done to
individuals and to society
by virtue of
the alumni behavior
coming out of these schools right like
you know
every every financial crime
that has
nearly destroyed the economy
on a scale of damage to individual lives
is incalculable relative relative to
someone who's a victim of pickpocketing
pickpocketing burglary or something else
and by the way
homicide is a tiny part of criminal
offenses about five percent violent
crime so most of what is crime and
causes us to have mass incarceration
is not killing somebody but something
else and often something quite petty
so
i point out that
that economists today are still using
that framework they're still judging
whether a school is working or not based
on the crime rates of black kids who
attend them it's crazy it is totally
absurd
as if as if the value of the public good
itself ought to be judged against
whether or not people engage in criminal
activity uh because what we essentially
are is closing off is the possibility
that
there is only
there is nothing but association and
there is no causation and essentially
the drivers of anti-social behavior and
criminality
are
are separate and apart from
whether or not kids are
that school experience
but this is a legacy you know i i won't
give it all to hoffman um but he will
certainly advance the argument um
directly with regard to african
americans
so on the note that harvard yale and
princeton lead directly to crime
yeah
right
yeah i mean imagine imagine a roster i
mean you know i'm not an economist but
you could just take kind of the most
celebrated uh white-collar crime of the
last 50 years actually you know names
um sentences crime itself and then do an
estimate on the actual
uh damage to people's lives including
people killing themselves because they
lost a job or they you know whether you
know however it plays out the house
or house you name a mortgage and all the
violent crimes that resulted from or
domestic violence driven by economic uh
challenges which is a you know i'm not
the social scientist per se but this is
a major argument of social science that
domestic violence is often a consequence
of the difficult economic realities that
men in particular face so yeah i mean so
that's the point the choice we make for
the data we collect and the arguments we
make about it is an expression of power
itself
um and so you know hopefully our
students will learn that uh and they
will use their power wisely
on that wonderful note thank you so much
professor mohammed
that was
wonderful thank you
by your vital work thank you so much for
having me hope to see everybody in
person one day yeah we would like that
okay bye-bye bye everyone
you